دعونا نحضر على قناة سي إن إن سلمى عبد العزيز مباشرة
في لندن، وأنا معجب بما
يمكنك أن تخبرنا به أكثر عن سارة بيكون، هناك
الكثير من الأسئلة حول
مكان وجود رجل يُعرف بالجنرال
هرمجدون، وهو رجل يتمتع
بسمعة وحشية للغاية ولكنه  لم تتم رؤية الرجل المعروف أيضًا
بتنفيذ أوامر بوتين
في جميع أنحاء العالم، سيرجي سيرفكين،
منذ يوم السبت. هناك بعض
المصادر في مجتمع الصحفيين الروس
بين المدونين الروس
تقول إنه من المحتمل أن يكون قد تم
احتجازه بسبب معرفته المتقدمة
بتمرد بريجوسيان على
تقول مصادر أخرى في نهاية الأسبوع إن هذا
ببساطة ليس صحيحًا أن ابنته
تحدثت معه قائلة إنه يتمتع
بصحة جيدة. الكرملين نفسه،
وقد نفى المتحدث باسم الكرملين كل هذا
قائلاً إنها مجرد شائعات ولكن مرة أخرى
لم يظهر علنًا منذ أيام
آخر مرة تمت مشاهدته فيها كانت في مقطع
الفيديو الذي شاهدته في ذلك التقرير هناك يوم
الجمعة فقط، حيث بدأ التمرد المسلح الذي قام به
باغوسيان بمناشدة
شخص باغوسي يعتبره
حليفًا وصديقًا، شخصًا عمل معه بشكل
وثيق في أوكرانيا، مناشدًا  عليه
أن يوقف هذا التمرد ولكن إذا
ألقيت نظرة فاحصة على هذا الفيديو، فإنه
يبدو أشعثًا بعض الشيء وغير حليق ويبدو
أنه يقرأ من
نص نظرًا للطريقة التي
يتحدث بها وبطريقة متوقفة، لذا مرة أخرى هناك
الكثير من الأسئلة ولماذا  هل نتحدث
عنه، لماذا هو مهم للغاية لأنه
قائد القوات الجوية الروسية
لأنه عضو النخبة في
الجيش الروسي لأنه
شخصية موثوقة للرئيس بوتين وربما كان
لديه مرة أخرى معرفة متقدمة
بالتمرد المسلح  إذن هناك بعض الأسئلة
هنا، ما مدى عمق هذا الخيانة في
القيادة العسكرية الروسية، هل
حصل إيفجيني براغوسيان على دعم شخص
مثل سيرجي ساروفكين وآخرين داخل
الجيش الروسي؟ هل هذا الشقاق مرة أخرى
بين بريجوسيان ووزير الدفاع
سيرجي شوكو والقائد الأعلى للجيش
غراسام؟  حول مدى عمق الأمر
وبشكل عام بالطبع إذا تراجعت خطوة إلى
الوراء. السؤال الأوسع هو هل لا يزال
الرئيس بوتين يتمتع بالقيادة
والسيطرة الكاملة على جيشه خاصة
أثناء خوضه حربًا،
هناك العديد من الأسئلة التي ما زلنا
ننتظر العديد من الإجابات عليها  قدرات سمك السلمون
في لندن شكرا جزيلا